la ministre de la culture et des
communications nathalie roy est avec
nous ce soir nathalie roy bonsoir c'est
fini est ce que vous considérez que vous
avez bien compris bien entendu les
critiques qui ont été faites après les
premières annonces que vous avez fait
notamment du milieu des arts de la scène
il ya des gens qui vous ont quand même
critiqué sévèrement
je pense à martin faucher du ft à
olivier kemeid également j'espère avoir
répondu à leurs préoccupations je pense
que le plan de relance qu'on vienne
déposer aujourd'hui prouve deux choses
de que la culture est importante et de
deux que un plan de relance fans de ce
griffonne poste coin d'une table en
quelques jours après une critique dans
un journal par exemple mais ça fait cinq
semaines minimalement que nous y
travaillons donc ce qu'on vient face que
le gouvernement vient de faire c'est
d'insuffler de l'oxygène qui donnait de
l'espoir je l'espère à tout le milieu
culturel en mettant 400 millions de
dollars à la disposition du milieu
culturel
c'est majeur monsieur filho petit si on
prend ce 400 millions ajoutés au budget
qui est là qui existe toujours c'est 1
971 millions que le gouvernement du
québec consacre uniquement à la culture
c'est un bond de 26 pour cent
comparativement à notre premier budget
que nous avions déposé en 2019 2020 donc
jeudi en conférence de presse que ce qu
on y est rare là c'est de donner un
outil puissant pour aider la création
parce qu'on est dans une période où tout
a changé tout a bougé et les artistes
doivent avancer à travailler mais bon
c'est bien il ya encore des gens
aujourd'hui dans le milieu des arts de
la scène qui disent parfait on parle
peut-être d'ouvrir des salles de
spectacles avant la saint jean mais par
exemple est-ce qu'on va ouvrir des
salles de spectacles à 25 % de capacité
est ce que vous êtes capable de dire ça
voilà alors à cet égard là aujourd'hui
savez que c'est la direction de la santé
publique qui donne les feux verts
il ya un premier feu vert qui était
donnée aujourd'hui je suis très contente
pour le 8 juin prochain prochain pardon
pour tout le secteur de l'audiovisuel
qu'est ce que c'est ce sont tous les
tournages peu importe en télévision un
cinéma qui pourront
avant c est également la pré-production
et la postproduction donc on peut
recommencer mais avec un guide
il ya un guide qui a été mis en place
qui est et qui comble acteurs du milieu
on a bien on a bien compris ça madame
roy mais est ce que les salles de
spectacles pourront rouvrir à 25 pour sa
de capacités voilà mais on ne sait pas
alors c'est là que je m'en venais parce
que c'est la direction de la santé
publique qui va décider quel sera le
pourcentage de capacités admissibles
dans les salles et c'est pour ça qu'on
vit avec cette incertitude on ne sait
pas quelle sera la capacité des sages
cependant la direction de la santé
publique nous a confirmé nous a permis
de dire quelle part est en mesure de
dire que ben oui les salles de
spectacles pourront rouvrir a compté
nous le souhaitons de la fête nationale
peut-être juste un peu avec man
comprends qu'on ne sait pas s'il y aura
du public à l'intérieur
et s'il y en a à quelle hauteur dans
quelle proportion avec elle pour
s'attacher pourquoi et pourquoi pas du
public et pourquoi pas faire confiance
aux gens du milieu des arts de la scène
les théâtres les salles de spectacle et
producteur avec justement des consignes
de santé publique aujourd'hui
j'entendais encore une fois martin
faucher qui disait on a pensé à des
programmes on est passé à une vision
dans des bureaux et des études aseptisé
de façon très théorique très
mathématique monde est loin des salles
de répétition loin des salles de
spectacle loin du milieu qui dit à sa
ministre
faites nous confiance écoutez je fais
totalement confiance par tout ce qui
nous a été proposé entre autres par les
groupes dont vous nous parler entre
autres par le conseil québécois du
théâtre
ils nous ont dit oui ils vont des
créatifs voici on pourrait faire ceci
cela tout ça a été remis entre les mains
de la direction de la santé publique
avec la cnss t&c la santé publique qui
donnera le feu vert qui dira telle
pratique oui on peut rouvrir si vous si
vous utilisez telle pratique vous
suggérez telle pratique tout ce qui a
été soumis par le milieu est analysé par
la direction de la santé publique
alors moi je leur fais confiance à 100%
au milieu c'est la santé publique qui
dira ce qu'elle accepte ou non pour
l'art
arthur madame le ministre les programmes
aujourd'hui est ce que ça vient ajouter
de l'administratif de la paperasse pour
les artistes pour les organisations pour
les entreprises qui doivent répondre à
de nouveaux appels à projets plutôt que
de tout simplement poursuivre leurs
projets leurs missions en respectant les
consignes de santé publique
pourquoi ne pas envoyer directement
l'argent à ces organisations
mais en partie de l'argent envoyé 50 %
des sommes qui devaient qui sont alloués
annuellement à différentes organisations
qui sont sous ministère de la culture
également du conseil des arts et des
lettres du québec qui ont été envoyés à
la fin mars début avril c'est une somme
importante on parle de 59 millions de
dollars qui ont déjà été envoyés à
différentes organisations
par ailleurs ce qu'on fait c'est que ces
appels à projets et ces programmes vont
être accélérés parce qu'on veut
absolument payer nos créateurs nos
artistes pour qu'ils travaillent avant
de remettre un pied sur scène par
exemple est d'ailleurs à cet égard là je
vous dirais toutes disciplines
confondues
on a doublé les bourses alors allez
demander aux artistes que ça signifie
ils soumettent un projet le calq il ya
des appels à projets ils soumettent
leurs noms
le cad approuvent ou désapprouvent alors
là les bourses seront doublés donc
convié soutenir de façon substantielle
les créateurs est-ce que l'avenir ne
serait-ce qu'à court terme du de la
diffusion passe par le numérique dans
votre esprit non c'est un outil c'est
pas l'avenir ça fait partie on nous
sommes en 2020
et force est de constater que tout ce
qui touche au numérique écrit on se
parle actuellement via numérique sinon
on ne pourrait pas se parler je voudrais
vous que le signal est jamais parfait
quand on parle par numérique donc je
j'ai des inquiétudes à me dire que je
vais regarder des spectacles numérique
en captation facetime par exemple moi
aussi et c'est pour ça que ce que nous
permettons avec les captations ça peut
être avec de vrais caméra aussi le fils
a pas diffusé par exemple sur des des
plateformes numériques ou des stations
télévision par exemple
la captation qui va être faite ne sera
pas nécessairement une captation fait
sur des plateformes ou avec des décors
exprimant de fortune on veut qu'un
justement entre autres les captations se
fasse mais de façon professionnelle et
que fait-on que fait on pour les
spectateurs pour les salles de
spectacles pour le lien humain dans les
prochains mois dans les 12 prochains
mois
écoutez si j'avais une boule de cristal
je vous répondrais le problème est qu'on
ne sait pas au moment où je vous parle
j'attends un feu vert la direction de la
santé publique on ne sait pas quel
moment les publics pourront revenir en
sage je suis pas plus tôt que tard je ne
souhaite cet été pour qu'on puisse avoir
un spectacle un humoriste chansonnier
une pièce de théâtre mais qui se
tiennent avec les mesures de
distanciation social tout est sur la
table tout sera possible
et c'est les artistes qui décideront la
façon dont ça pourra se faire avec
l'aval de la direction de la sa merci
beaucoup madame euros à merfy fait
plaisir